There is an Indian YouTube channel on the brink of becoming almost number one
It's taken us lot of effort to come this far to take my father, Mr. Christian Kumar's dream forward,
I started this channel. Today it belongs to you. It belongs to the entire nation. This is a historic moment for all of us
So let's come together and subscribe to t-series YouTube channel and make India proud. Hashtag bharatwins YouTube
Well, well, well WELL
Getting a little bit DESPERATE, are we?
T-series
"Oooh please subscribe"
"We have to be number one"
*cries in indian*
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
You know what
I smell I smell fear you're scared and you have every right to be scared because I am NOT just some ordinary youtuber
I'M THE CRAB KING!
Everyone in the comments: Crab king! Crab king!
This is what you are up against t-series. I hope you understand that you have absolutely no chance of survival
*crab king*
Krab king (x3) Come here. Come here. Oh
Look at you you're so cute. Don't be scared. Come to poppy. No no. Yep. Oh my god. I'm so sorry
Grab tea, sometimes killed by accident. That's how strong I am. Alright you come here
I
Don't like how you guys I'm legs give me the leg. Thanks Friday. These are my legs now go away Jesus Christ
Grab dude, ah
Stop it. Stop fighting
What the hell is he doing stop trying to taunt the scribe King come walk to poppy you can do it
Come to crab game, nope
Damn it. I don't want to kill him. Yeah
Yeah
This is what happens to all who oppose crab king something what when you're like stop moving your leg. There you go
Pray ding. Oh
You want your legs back here come get your leg it's right there you can do it. You're almost there you're touching it
Yeah, you have your leg now come to grab King for a little hug Oh
No, Oh No
Let me grab them
You fools you legless bastard you have nothing nothing what is this another leg?
Delicious no, nom nom. Nom, nom. Let's kick you in the face
Hmm. This is what I do with legs. Ah
Pick your nipple
Huh, are you gonna stop with the legs that's what I thought now give me those but once a free snack, there you go
Oh, no, no, no, no. No, he loves it. That was a gift. Oh
Yeah, baby, no, no turn around for me, baby
Oops, sorry
We can still harvest we can still use them. It's called recycling
Don't do it don't tell them I don't care
you foot like
Felix the prophecy said you have to befriend the feet. I don't care get him foot. I
Don't wanna hurt them shut up foot get him
Keep your face you're in the face because I don't like you crab King does not like
My legs
Anymore
More legs
There's so many legs to capture. There's so many I helped know what?
by myself
Can I jumble with them, I wonder if I can
Well, I can't I totally can
Wait, let me just read it. I need one that's alive. There you go. You're alive, right? Yeah, I'm fine, right?
It's a little hard to throw oh look they have chips now how possiblys crab can go to defeat this Oh No
Please go easy on me guys, please. Oh
What's that yours? I'm so sorry have it back?
They have freaking hammers. Where did you find that?
Here give me that give me the hammer. Give me the hammer. He made the ham game
800 I said give me hammer
God damn, this guy's strong let it go. Thank you. It's my hammer. Okay, you understand? Oh
No
Stop stop stop. I
Had enough don't come near me cracking very dangerous
Jesus Christ
Stop
Don't come near me
whoopsie
What am I hammer go? I won't have bosses on me and I should go back giant mode
What is a giant mode? I thought I was already pretty big boss rush old truck. Okay, now we have some stuff
Oh, wow. Okay, so that nut salute Hey which weapon am I going to pick?
I think the harpoon crab Kings hands are too big. He cannot grab please
I just want to grab okay fine. I'll go with that, please. Alright, I guess it's you
If you and me buddy, crab, crab, crab, crab, crab, crab, crab, crab crab. Hey, how you doing?
Don't hurt me, please
What did I say? Huh?
What did I say? You stupid idiot? I dunno why no, you're gonna have to cover your legs
What is this nah
Stop
Attack your nicing mate stop. How would you still moving? Oh god. It's the beaver guy. Oh god, I
Don't have time for you, please
Get that beavers. There's enough beavers Felix. Aha
They went for my face cracking don't hurt cracking. I'm a friend of the animals. Got you now beaver could
Ya come here. I died from beaver. God dammit. I know it's not a beaver. Okay, you can stop. What's your name?
Look at you
Whoa, it's free. Good jump. They're crazy. Stop it. Stop get the foot. I wanna get the pain. I
Spare your life in exchange for your feet. Those are the rules of the crab King now thanked. Crab king
What are you tryin tack? He's trying to fight back too bad. You have no chance
Please Felix, we'll subscribe
Not good enough. I don't care. I'm the one with the power Oh crab cake, crab cake knows some moves Oh
Oh god, it's the f****** beavers again. Don't don't I got a sword please. I don't want to hurt your beavers
I'm gonna have to clean off their legs
That's it
Nice and smooth. We're gonna have to amputate.
AAAAAAAAH It's got my face. It's on my face
GODD*** BEAVER get up get off
Krakens only weightless Jesus Christ stop. Oh
Oh, thank god, oh, thank god.
He's gonna jump he's gonna jump
And he shields.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah
You're scared, aren't you? Come here. Come here
OHOHOOOOOHOHOO
That was epic bros
Come on come on then
What the hell did he do that?
Question. Oh
Sorry, I didn't mean to crush your face. Oh god, no, no, no, no
Get out away from me get it away from me that oh
Thank god, maybe I'm a little too overpowered here maybe makes it roll too easy. So let's tone it down just a little bit
Oh, wow, I'm your weapon and salute. I am a very small crab
UMMM
I can't
Can't reach the hose. Ah,
*CRAB KING INTENSIFIES*
Alright, we know how to do this
GO FOR DA KNEES
AAAAAAAAAAA
GAH AH AAAAAAAAAAAA
*evil pewds laugh*
BAH BAH BAH HA
FOOT... FOOT ATTACK
Ah
I tore his rear end in half.
Oh my God, he's giant. How could I possibly fight back?
Got him
Super strength crab
I got his knee pads
His knees are exposed
Still alive look at me look at me?
Look at me
LOOK AT ME
Look at me when I'm talking to you
No, oh god they're giant now
*crab crawl*
HUAH
How is that possible ah
BAH
*existential crisis*
here it goes
BDGAAYAA
What's happening I'm losing my heart
No.....
WUAAH
HYAAH
IT WENT BACKWARDS!?!?!
HWAAAAH
Gotta retreat
The battle is lost, but not the whole war
Oh god, you can make it... the door is right there
Ha ha ha crank things right? Whoa. Oh
Oh god. Oh god. I'm not gonna make it huh? Huh Oh,
*more crab crawling*
Almost there, huh? OH
Almighty crab strength
*Felix charging his special move*
HIS POWER LEVEL IS OVER 9000
BAH
Crab king will stop, but one day..... crab king will return
Tuber simulator, is now so relevant, that it's got a brand new minigame
CRANIAC
drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more... OF COURSE THERE IS
new knowledge perks, new quests, and new Pixelings AND LEGS
guys
legs
WELL WHAT ARE YOU WAITING FOR, DOWNLOAD IT
Also, sub to Pewds
Have a nice day :D